and I'm it people are pretty boring you
can see what they're up to
usually not up to much and I should
probably let her know that I'm able to
see her well that's really unsettling
yeah
I'm in on all this let me explain I
asked Alexander Hyde the chief research
officer at security scorecard and a
certified ethical hacker to break into
my webcams to see just how vulnerable I
was with some deliberate negligence on
my part he got into my Windows 10
laptop's webcam and from there a
connected baby monitor on my home Wi-Fi
network he also eventually cracked my
MacBook Air - although both operating
systems were initially able to thwart
the hacker why in the world would I ask
someone to spy on me honest answer
because I've been seeing lots of these
webcam covers and I wanted to know if
they were really needed we've put
cameras everywhere
so how secure are they and what can we
be doing to better protect our literal
privacy Alex was able to get into my
Windows laptop's webcam by spearfishing
me that's what a hacker poses as someone
you may know and entices you to open
documents or links I made his job easier
by posting on Twitter recently that I
was looking to hire a new video producer
Alex I mean rudiger Watkins sent me an
email with a resume and a link to a
video real those of course contained
malware and I needed to download both
for the hack to work I was a very
willing participant in this hack and for
the purposes of this exercise I did what
you should never do I disabled antivirus
ignored plenty of warnings from Gmail
windows and Microsoft Office
once the malware was in place it was
just a few steps on his end to get into
my webcam and possibly worse lots of
data stored on my laptop when you have
this level of access
essentially anything that's anything
that's on that network is accessible in
the same ways
on Windows he was able to snap a photo
every few seconds and even listen in
over the mic yes that's my son crying in
the background microsoft says it patched
this vulnerability in 2017
that's why Alex needed both files to
carry out the hack and why it's built in
Windows Defender issued multiple
warnings getting into the Mac was a
different process
he sent a document that required
LibreOffice to be installed yet again I
ignored the warnings
I had to override protections to
download the app change some security
settings in the app itself and even give
the program access to my camera not
exactly a covert operation eventually he
did get in and snapped a few photos an
apple spokesperson said the following
Apple has built security features into
Mac OS to protect users from mistakenly
downloading unsafe software we recommend
downloading software only from the Mac
App Store our trusted members of the
Apple Developer Program and never
opening files from unknown or untrusted
sources with both the Mac and the HP
laptops the webcam lights turned on I
asked Alex to go one step further to see
if he can get into this man's view IP
baby monitor I set up on my home network
because he was already in the laptop and
could see the network activity he could
see the IP address for the webcam then
since I hadn't changed the admin
password on the camera because the app
didn't prompt me to he was able to pull
up a live view of my son's playroom a
Juan's view representative said the
setup process requires default settings
for technical reasons and stressed the
importance of changing the password
later he wasn't able to get into my nest
camera because he didn't have my
username and password I met up with Alex
and he walked me through how he did all
this using off-the-shelf hacking tools
with more time and resources however he
said it could have more craftily tricked
me into falling for his attack he also
told me hackers are generally interested
in finding something more valuable than
a view of you at your computer there has
to be real motivation on the hackers
part oftentimes a hacker is seeking to
make money or monetize some type of
resource that's been obtained during the
breach
if someone specifically just seeking
access to a web cam chances are there's
there's enough
another motive there all this hacking
wasn't in vain I quickly learned four
things I needed to do to mitigate the
risk of someone with actual evil intents
peering into my home and life number one
if you have a Windows PC antivirus is
still a must Windows tenth built-in live
defender issued a warning and prevented
me from downloading the malicious file
or video real on a Mac installed malware
bytes or other malware fighting software
on both a Mac and PC make sure your
operating system is up-to-date
the same goes for your smart phone home
cameras and Wi-Fi router attackers will
often embark in a sophisticated social
engineering ruse to tell the user how to
disable these protections in order to
have the attack work number two think
before you click on links or attachments
included in emails texts and social
media posts that even just seem the
slightest bit off plus pay attention to
those warnings that appear in your email
or web browser after you click something
malicious number three no matter what
the device always change the admin
password and for the love of everything
don't repeat passwords don't believe me
Alex had access to a public database
with millions of usernames and passwords
from previous breaches see what we got
is that you but you shouldn't be using
those anymore
number four cover that webcam I bought
this $9 pack on Amazon but a post-it or
a piece of tape will do the trick
what are the chances of someone wanting
to watch you and you're not exactly
thrilling life I'd rather not find out I
still see you
[Music]